hello with the World Championship coming
up and lots of questions about how I
prepare for my games I thought I'd give
you my top 13 tips about chess
tip number one you can learn from almost
every game and everyone play against
people from all different levels at
different time controls from all around
the world
tip number two my best tip of all
challenge yourself by playing against
play - app
tip number three take regular breaks
from chess train your body as well as
your mind
tip number four now it would appear that
I have to go back on naming tip number
two the most important one because this
is the most important one have fun
playing chess
tip number five expand your horizons try
different openings different ways of
playing in order to broaden your
understanding of the game
tip number six challenge your brain with
other puzzles it will improve your
problem-solving skills
tip number seven get enough sleep from
when I was young
till the hm now I always try to get at
least nine hours of sleep every every
day when I'm playing tournaments it's
vital to keep a clear head
tip number eight eat and drink well my
favorite drink while playing is orange
juice mixed with water as probably most
of you know
tip number nine learn from watching
others I have put a few movies in the
app that you can learn from
tip number 10 sit at the chessboard and
play against yourself it will improve
your feel for the game
tip number eleven study past players
learn learn from their games and
incorporate their techniques into your
own play
tip number 12 fight till the end
never give up whether you're playing for
win or fighting for a draw
13 chest takes practice don't give up
do you want to start with a different ah
I'm are we ready to go be in the
comments below
hello hello hello yes like that tip
number 10 Sita Sita the chessboard and
play with yourself it's amazing ah okay
yes